[Musique]
jour après jour sur le radar de l'équipe
des décrypteurs on voit passer toutes
sortes de publication est certaine nous
laisse le plus perplexe que d'autres
disons prenez par exemple de cette
publication au sujet de laquelle vous
avez été nombreux à nous écrire et mon
collègue des filles et elle a décortiqué
pour vous elle laisse entendre qu un
black-out généralisée va se produire
dans la foulée de la pandémie de kobe 19
conséquences concrètes de cette théorie
l'accès au web et à la téléphonie mobile
seraient momentanément coupées et le
président américain dans notre homme
peut procéder à l'arrestation de
centaines de milliers de citoyens
qualifiés de traîtres ce qui se
produirait à ce moment là serait que sur
ordre du président des citoyens
américains passeraient aux aveux sur
toutes les chaînes télévisées du pays
des stars d'hollywood des journalistes
et des membres du parti démocrate qui
avouerait alors être à l'origine de
crimes sordides de parmi ceux-ci
satanisme et prélèvements de sécrétions
corporelles dans des cadavres d'enfants
pour la production d'une drogues
psychotropes faut toutes ces théories
ont un point commun elles n'ont aucun
sens pour le commun des mortels
on se comprend et elle les émane d'une
théorie conspirationniste baptisé yoann
en bref le mouvement qu on n a pris
racine dans les bas-fonds d'internet
plus précisément dans le forum en ligne
faute chan un utilisateur anonyme
surnommé qiu a commencé à laisser
flotter la rumeur non fondée de
l'arrestation imminente de hillary
clinton
cet individu ku affirmait être une
personne haut placée dans
l'administration trump bien au fait des
préparatifs en vue d'une tempête
orchestrée par le président américain
menant à d'éventuelles arrestations de
traîtres aussi échevelé soit elle cette
théorie a des conséquences concrètes
un homme se revendiquant de qiu a
assassiné en 2019 un membre bien en vue
du crime organisé new york est convaincu
que la victime faisait partie d'un vaste
complot révélée par tous et un bureau du
fbi à phoenix en arizona
on a qualifié la conspiration qui ou de
menaces terroristes domestique
une première pour un mouvement
conspirationnistes aux états unis des
doutes sur ce que vous voyez passer sur
le web en cette ère de pandémie avant de
le partager
faites nous signe décrypteurs au pluriel
un commercial radio trait d'union
canada.ca et n'oubliez pas d'adhérer à
notre groupe facebook
salut
[Musique]